the edging out a star's born for best
drama castles little surprised by this a
little surprise I was sitting over here
almost in tears a star's born only going
1 4 5 but well deserved to the entire
Bohemian Rhapsody
cast and crew beautiful film but a
surprise I'm not gonna lie on a little
bias because I just was so obsessed with
the Stars born when I saw it I know you
were too Bohemian Rhapsody though if
you're a queen fan I mean that was the
movie for you it was incredible with a
stellar performance by Rami Malek who
actually picked up the Golden Globe for
Best Actor in a Drama right before they
awarded Bohemian Rhapsody another upset
first I was born right there but Rami
though completely transforms into Fred
Freddie Mercury was actually a pretty
amazing to watch especially if you guys
have seen it that last 20 minutes where
they're playing the live 8 are the the
yeah the Live Aid concert it was
something else so congrats to Rami but
yeah they're shaking up a stars board we
were predicting it to sweep a little Oh
at the beginning tonight I said it was
gonna go 5 4 5 they got one for fun ha
ha ha ha Pop's that pops that but you
know we also got to give a shout out to
Best Actress winner and Glenn Close
here's what she had to say in her
acceptance speech
you know women where were nurturers that
that's what's expected of us we have our
children we have our husbands if we're
lucky enough and our partners whoever
but we have to find personal fulfillment
we have to fill our
follow our dreams
we have to say I can do that and I
should be allowed to do that
powerful and impassion and very
emotional speech from Glenn Close who
picked up her third Golden Globe but
believe it or not that is actually
Glenn's first Globe for acting in a
movie she has two previous Globes for
acting on TVs damages and the miniseries
the line in winter that was for a movie
role but also get this cast she still
has never won an Oscar hard to believe
especially with fifteen Golden Globe
nominations under her belt like you said
third win I mean her first win was back
in 2005 this wind comes 2019 I mean big
night for her and her speech just
talking about the power of dreaming
right for women - or women yeah
exercising their agency you know you
mentioned it's her 15th Golden Globe
nomination the first time she was
nominated was way back in 1985 and I
actually caught up with Glenn at the
back to tea party just yesterday or I
asked her I said 15 Golden Globe
nominations has the novelty worn off
right without missing a beat she said
absolutely not it's still feel special
crazy thing is that when she won her
face was like Glenn Close didn't even
know Glenn Close was gonna win she was
taken by such a surprise and I think
that's one of the most beautiful moments
of the Golden Globes is when you're in a
category with such talented remarkable
other women and you really don't give
yourself the benefit of the benefit of
the doubt you don't think you're gonna
win and then there you go you win you
know I think has a lot to say with the
fact that she was also up against Lady
gaga yeah I mean everyone like me
thought she was gonna win right well you
know what Cheryl Gaga was the one that
had to show your performance right you
know the one that you kind of remember
herzl everything was so much more
nuanced for Glenn you know to me and for
an indie film that a lot of people
didn't see but I think when it comes to
longevity Glenn's obviously had that
with her career and it's kind of time
for her to take her first acting Globe
it's good being in a movie well
congratulations to Glenn Close another
one of the biggest moments from the
Golden Globes had to be when Sandra Oh
took home the gold for Best Performance
by an actress in a television series
drama for her role in killing Eve Sandra
is the first Asian woman to win multiple
Golden Globes I know
everyone in our watch party was in tears
erupted for her especially during her
speech when she thanked her parents it
was just it's one of those moments her
last win was of course in 2006 for
Grey's Anatomy with hosting tonight and
being nominated and just having that win
now just I could imagine she's only on
cloud nine I mean it was a huge night
for Sandra and what an amazing speech
we're gonna play you guys a little clip
of it for you right now take a look
thank you so much but mostly there are
two people here tonight that I am so
grateful for that they're here with me
I'd like to to thank my mother and my
father
[Applause]
come on Cass that was that was the
moment I'm telling you during the watch
party I I got some good eyelashes on
today so I couldn't cried too much
during stuff she had me in tears I will
say Grey's Anatomy is one of my all-time
favorite shows and that's where I first
fell in love with Sandra oh and I mean
just her transition from Grey's to
killing Eve and you know having this win
now under her belt so well-deserved and
thanking her parents like that seeing
how emotional she got I mean just
infectious well earlier than the night
she actually tweeted a photo of her
parents in front of a killing billboard
and said only took 30 years but my
parents are pretty proud you know what's
even more interesting though is the
hurry co-host Andy Samberg they
predicted her win way before they
actually took the stage here's what he
said to Kelty night earlier this week we
have a clip for you guys right now
Sandra Oh with Kelsey night on the our
Scooby Andy Samberg with Kelsey night
let's take a look at that celebrity
who's most likely to make us cry with
our acceptance speech mmm
Sandra oh hey do you want to avoid
backstage they called it what do they do
[Music]
I mean you gotta say it out loud for it
to happen right that's exactly where
it's been funny cuz all week long
killing Eve they've been tweeting on
their official account about how she is
deserving of this award
look they manifested it too on social
media she was already a winner tonight
though I gotta say she was the first
Asian American woman to host the Golden
Globes and I thought they did a stellar
job would you think 100% and I will say
with winning the award I got to add a
Shonda Rhimes took to Twitter just
sometimes simple is almost better and
she just tweeted
Sandra's handle her Twitter handle and
then like a couple explanation points
and I feel like that is all of our moods
to just we cannot find the words to say
like I said it is a well deserved award
for Sandra amazing that Shonda came
through on that tweet though I mean
you know Sandra was on the show for ten
seasons for 2005 to 2014 but something
tells me she's gonna be killing you for
a long alright guys we are breaking down
the biggest and most talked about
moments of the Golden Globe Awards I
mean there's so many to choose from like
we mentioned of course Sandra Oh's big
win and also Regina Keegan
she nabbed her first Golden Globe y'all
she won Best Supporting Actress for her
turn and Beale Street guitars and use
her speech to make a powerful promise
just take a look I am making a vow and
it's going to be tough make sure that
everything that I produce that is 50
percent women and I just challenged
anyone out there
anyone out there who is in a position of
power not just in our industry in all
industries I challenge you to challenge
yourselves and stand with us in
solidarity and do the same I gotta say
Regina King man she hasn't been an award
show darling she has collected three
Emmys to her name because of a American
crime she was previously nominated for a
Globe for that show in 2016 but her
first win for a film and she has not
been in a movie in a hot minute
listen well-deserved for her this movie
it feels straight cooked right
absolutely beautiful I had to watch it
twice just to really make sure I got
every single just shot of that movie
some of her scenes were just so powerful
I'm not I'm not surprised she took this
absolutely all right now to one of the
biggest backstage moments just moments
after actress Patricia Clarkson won for
Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role in a television series
for sharp objects
she joined et's Kevin Frazier backstage
after her big win take a look
mom you're on speakerphone we're on
Entertainment Tonight I'm calling you
yes right now and I'm calling you I love
you mom I know mom how great is this and
I'm so thankful to you and dad and you
know I think all the music didn't come
up and I got to thank you
I think look I'm gonna go I'll call you
later okay you're gonna have a whole
world calling okay I love you mom
leave it to Entertainment Tonight to
capture such a sweet and beautiful
intimate moment I mean calling her mom
backstage during her interview with EADS
he after her windows you gotta give your
parents buy some props because you know
I said this earlier but going through
the career that you have as an actor or
an actress you know there's a lot of
sites a crisis that you have to make as
a family and your parents are owed a lot
I feel like but um I did talk to
Patricia yesterday at the Gold meets
gold and red carpet they asked her the
big question obviously sharp objects is
a limited series and you know at first
one of the producers Marti Noxon she
said there's no way that there's gonna
be a season two then a tone changed to
Never Say Never and so I asked Patricia
about that from from the producer so I
asked Patricia about this yesterday and
she said well when you're working with
HBO you never know so season two out of
nowhere that's right like there's hope
for a sharp more there is oh well it
wouldn't be the Golden Globes without an
iconic fashion we gotta talk okay it is
a sharp jacket but we got to talk about
Lady gaga
losing Judy Garland vibes yes living for
this we gotta talk about this amazing
dress oh it's phenomenal I understand it
was inspired by Judy Garland this is
true oh look you know what I don't I
we didn't say that no but it it looks an
awful lot like that she looks beautiful
no with this this is Valentino couture
creation for me custom yeah I mean but
maybe you you're like oh go with that
yes I'll go with this why not that's
special except I'm missing the gloves oh
yeah well we'll just need to go buy you
a pair a pair of long like love's right
I know the universe works in mysterious
ways she did not even do that
intentionally she just surprisingly
Channel Judy Garland from a star's born
somewhere dorothy was that the
university's on its yo doan't right
there on our ET platform leather gloves
revealing agaaca
that there's a special little moment
there even though Gaga may have not
taken home you know the award that she
the awards up plural that maybe she was
hoping for I will say no fashion expert
but she does get like a ten out of ten
any fashion award give up for me in my
book it was all the drama that we come
to expect of Lady Gaga and get all in
all were you did spot that again and
Christiane Karina was on the red carpet
supporting her and she's sharing a
little sweet kiss with create a
Christian or fiance after she picked up
their Best Original Song man that dress
look good walking across that stage but
you know we have to talk about guys it's
the social moment stealing the show that
would be the Fiji water girl on the red
carpet I mean this girl behind every
photo opportunity she knows but her but
this is so smart on her part but she
just look at her face look at her face
see it's like she knows it in the way
that better make it count this she she
found her angle she's serving days and
now the Internet's going crazy about her
she's the Fiji water girl forever I hate
to say this but she kind of overshadowed
Idris Elba's daughter who was the Golden
Globes ambassador because everyone's
talking about the Fiji water girl I mean
everyone is becoming the meme
all over the internet of course it would
the Fiji water girl is me trying to act
nonchalant but also sir face and a
backup of club photos is sure that face
I mean so just calculated that little
smirk right alright here's another one
there could be 100 Fiji waters on the
red carpet but it only takes one to
quench your thirst and that's a her
actually that supposed to be the alley
billboard from a stars born on Sunset
Boulevard you did is good feed you wanna
go thank you for that gift the gift that
keeps on giving
speaking of so the man that blew us away
tonight
rami malek and we loved what he had to
say in the speech after winning the
Golden Globe for Bohemian Rhapsody let's
take a listen thank you to Freddie
Mercury for giving me the joy I could
listen to Rami Malek singing gorgeous
and walk on a loop someone make that a
gift please it's a good thing it's the
beginning of Awards who's that I know
right which means we're gonna get some
killer fashion from Rami Malek he's been
killing it and slaying it on the red
carpet and now he's a Golden Globe
winner to boot well I feel like this
just sets the tone for the rest of
awards season which kind of breaks my
heart a little bit for a star is born
but hey gotta give Bohemian Rhapsody
credit where credit it is kind of early
to call those still we were right this
is the first major award show of the
season the long race to the Oscars a
stars born though definitely did get a
little shutout today at the Golden
Globes after only not being won Golden
Globe out of her original song out of
five it was nominated for a Best Picture
Drama Best Actor Bradley Cooper best Oh
better
Bradley Cooper also best actress Lady
Gaga but there's still hope you all we
still got the Critics Choice Awards the
SAG Awards the Grammy Awards you don't
talk to Gaga on the platform on the et
platform on the red carpet about helping
Bradley get his first Grammy nomination
she goes I love it he's a real musician
he deserves it you know I listen there's
also hope for the CMT CMA
no Best New Artist give it to Bradley
Cooper Jackson a moment at the CMT
Awards you're right real quick
I also chatted with Mark Ronson who of
course accepted Best Original Song with
Lady Gaga I talked to him yesterday at
the Baptist Yves Agra what are the
chances we can get Bradley Lady gaga
to perform shallow at the Grammys he
said it's not up to him but he's hoping
aren't we all
we are hoping we have to give a huge
congratulations to all of the winners
tonight at the Golden Globes well
deserved and we're still here thank you
for joining us joining us guys ready to
keep this party going so head over to
the live stream on UT live you can also
download our app we are available on
roku Apple TV Amazon fire Android and
iOS so sick of the stream easy live is
[Music]